-Did you get the cotton candy
out of your nose or whatever?
-In my nose. And, like -- and
the cotton candy with the water
just makes sugar everywhere.
Yeah.
-Tough act to follow you
with Aaron Judge, man.
Whew!
-How about you --
-What a stud that dude is.
-How about you two studs
in the hallway?
Back there, I'm like,
"Oh, my gosh."
-What is he, 7'4"?
-8'9."
-He's huge!
[ Laughter ]
-8 foot 9 --
[ Laughs ]
He's just a beast of a dude.
-He's a big dude.
-Yeah, nice guy.
Hey, I want to get to you.
Come on.
-Okay, sorry.
-I missed you.
Since I've seen you,
you actually got married
a few months ago.
-I did!
-Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-I'm so happy for you, bud.
-That's awesome.
-I did. I did.
Barely.
-Yeah, barely.
No -- barely.
-Barely.
Oh, I mean, I had a little
mishap the night before.
-Yeah?
-The night before -- so,
the night before the wedding,
we had this party, like,
a wedding rehearsal,
dinner rehearsal.
-Yeah.
-And we had a party bus, and we
had a band and the whole thing.
And I tried to do this Russian
sort of gymnast routine
in the back of the party bus
on the way home,
and I threw my back out.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
And I didn't know it
until the next morning
when I couldn't get out of bed.
-Wedding --
-Went to the hospital, got shot
up, medication, perfectly fine.
I was -- I was mostly worried
because I'm a bit older
than she is,
and so I figured if --
if I don't make it down the --
if I can't walk down
the aisle...
[ Laughter ]
-You'll never --
You'll never outlive that.
It's like, "Here he comes."
-Can you imagine a walker?
-"Come on, Grandpa!
Come on!
Come on, Grandpa!
It's your wedding day!"
-"I'm coming! I'm coming!"
-"Don't play any music!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I mean, it was a --
it was a real possibility.
-But you made it.
-I was thinking, wheelchair,
crutches, or a walker.
-You made it.
-I made it.
-At least put the aisle
downhill.
So, you don't have to --
[ Laughter ]
You don't have to do any work.
But, no, you made it.
Not only that, you crushed it.
You sent us a video
of the wedding.
I want to show this
and then talk about this.
Here's Josh Duhamel.
-♪ Lay your weary head to rest ♪
♪ Don't you cry no more ♪
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Come on, that's --
-I mean --
-"Carry on my Wayward --"
-What do you guys think?
-"Carry on Wayward Son."
Roots say "thumbs up."
There you go.
They love it.
Dude, that's pretty great.
-Oh.
Well, I also had Chris Hawkey
in the background there sort of
making me sound a lot better
than I was.
-But is that --
is that your go-to song?
Have you done that before?
-No, they were singing it.
And I knew the -- I knew, like,
the main verse to the song.
I didn't know
the rest of the lyrics.
I was like,
"I'm gonna get up there."
-Yeah.
-So, I went up and I --
I just -- it was my wedding.
I can do what I want to, right?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And you're on all that
back medication.
Might as well just go for it.
[ Laughter ]
-I was -- I was high!
-You won't remember this
till tomorrow anyway.
Yeah, exactly, yeah.
-I don't remember any of that.
-Dude, that's fantastic.
That's a fun -- that's a fun
human being to have at a party.
That looks like a concert.
-Thank you.
I don't remember any of it,
but, yeah, it was good.
[ Laughter ]
-Let's -- can we talk about
"Shotgun Wedding"?
-Yeah, sure, sure.
-Jennifer Lopez.
-Yeah.
-One of our pals of all pals.
I love Jennifer Lopez.
-Me too.
-How long have you known
Jennifer?
-I met her, like, 15 years ago.
-Yeah.
-So, I've known her -- you know,
certainly, we'd run into
each other here and there over
the last however many years.
But it came up, and they wanted
me to do the part, and we met,
and the main thing was for me
was, we have to make sure that,
you know,
they believe us as a couple.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You know?
-Of course.
-Because, you know,
she's a huge superstar.
And it's hard to, like, get --
you would think it would be hard
to get to her that way.
But she's not.
She's, like, the --
she's still
"Jenny from the block."
-Oh, yeah.
-She really is.
She really is still
"Jenny from the block."
-But I can see you guys --
I think it's perfect.
-I would watch anything
you guys did together.
-Oh, thank you.
It's a fun movie.
-I love that.
I love her.
I love you, you guys together.
You're both funny.
She's -- She's a pro.
-I mean, she is.
But, you know,
with some really nice editing,
they made me funny, too,
believe it or not.
-No, no.
You're always funny.
Where did you film it?
-Dominican Republic.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You ever been?
-No, I'm dying to go.
-Dude, it's beautiful.
-It's just gorgeous, right?
-It is, it is.
-It almost feels like not work.
-Well, that's the beauty of this
job is you get to go places
you would never otherwise see.
And then not only that
but see places -- you're not
just going to Punta Cana,
you're going to, like,
north, south, east, west
of, you know, all the most
beautiful spots.
-Yeah.
-So, we had a blast
with Lenny Kravitz
and Cheech Marin and...
-Yeah.
-...and Jennifer Coolidge.
-Jennifer Coolidge,
by the way --
-Jennifer Cool-- yeah.
-Jennifer Coolidge
plays your mom in this.
-She plays --
[ Laughter ]
She had me when she was 7.
-Yeah, of course.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Dude, how fun
is Jennifer Coolidge?
-She's amazing!
I mean, Jennifer Coolidge
is a -- she reminds me
a little bit of
what it might've been like
to work with an Andy Kaufman
or, like, Bill Murray or
somebody who you never know
what the hell they're gonna do.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Because she would
just do things.
We're all like,
"Do you want another take?"
She's like, "No, I'm good."
Like, "I guess that's what
you want to do."
And then you see it on screen,
and it's brilliant.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She nailed it.
-She's amazing.
And she's so chill.
She's just --
she's an amazing woman.
-It's kind of got everything
in it.
It's got comedy, it's romantic,
but also, it's action.
-Yeah.
-How do we --
-Big, broad sort of action.
-Yes.
But how do we --
There's pirates involved.
-There are pi-- yes.
There are pirates involved
who take over this island.
-Yeah.
-Or this -- yeah, this island
in the Philippines.
We shot it in the Dominican,
but it's supposed to be
the Philippines.
And they sort of --
they overtake the wedding
to sort of take ransom --
take money from her father.
-Yeah. And the only two people
that they didn't capture --
-Yeah, 'cause we were off
having a little tiff
before the actual event, so...
-I want to show a clip.
Here are Josh Duhamel
and Jennifer Lopez
in "Shotgun Wedding."
Take a look at this.
-[ Grunting ]
-Aah!
-Cliff! Cliff!
-I see it!
Get it into park!
-I'm trying!
[ Both grunting ]
-Oh, God!
Oh, my God!
-[ Grunting ]
-Oh! Slide down!
Oh!
[ Sighs ]
-Oh!
[ Both laugh ]
-Unh!
-Ohh!
-My dress!
My dress is caught!
Don't let go!
-Don't you let go!
-Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Josh Duhamel, everybody!
"Shotgun Wedding"
begins streaming this Friday
on Prime Video.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
Josh Duhamel, come on.